Mark: Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Outlast 2!
Okay. All right a little -
Yeah, okay. I-
Okay-
Uh-huh?
Yeah, okay? I was just about to catch all them up to exactly what you just said - so can you let me do my job?
And then you do whatever the hell, you're about to walk into. I don't know if I want to go there!
Hi!
You can hide by crouching under water. Do I need to?
Oh I do oh,  agh, I forget how to crouch-
A-bleugh! Good thing my camera's waterproof!
Peek?
Oh! He's looking at me.
Okay, that's not good.
Hi, hi friend.
What are you looking for?
Are you looking for a heretic or are you a heretic?
I imagine that we must be in the center of the cult village i-
Oh-hey-
If we're so close-to where we need to be-for that search-and find Lynn
Guessing that I can't stay down here indefinitely
So I'm gonna pop back up, and then I'm gonna meander my way over there
All right
Again, don't really know how I'm keeping this (camera)dry
But I think I see - yeah - this over here.
Yeah, just jump for joy in front of every window you see then.
God damn it, okay.
So we need to find more batteries; more everything. We need to find Lynn.
We need to get the heckie out of here.
Oh yeah, real subtle with that window there.
What are you doing?! Stop jumping for joy!
Oh boy.
Uh oh.
Okay, so I can make it - if he doesn't sweep over to the left - then I can make it
I'm gonna go go go go.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go,  i'm gonna go, I'm gonna - sploosh!
Sploosh down!
Seems like I'm fine-
Eaurgh-oh, I'm not fine!
All right, I'm fine.
Underwater.
Good thing - I was an Olympic-level swimmer when I was a kid.
Able to hold my breath for 10 minutes at a time-
Yeee-ah! Okay, all right then.
The whoring of our children?
The fuck are you talking about?
Oh, yeah, okay, finally geez!
Go away, you goof.
You frickin' - Wha - I don't know what I did, but I sidestepped somewhere.
Okay,
Just gotta open this-
Hi!
Holy shit! That's bright!
Oh! Good, I'm trapped in my memories
Okay good. I still have this thing.
Oh, I vague recollections about this.
Yeah, what the hell? You're already here.
Why not both?
Porque no los dos?
Oh!
Hi!
Huh?
Mark: Okay?
Yeah, why am I able to record this?
What in the world is that bright shining light?
What does it do to the people in this town?
What kind of influence does it have over the people here?
That's so weird.
I don't need to - waste that.
Oh, good okay. What is this?
Mark: Oh! You were high school sweethearts from the very beginning.
Yuegh-egh.
Ugh, is that me? Yeuh-ugh. Yuegh-egh.
Is that -
ME!?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, what's up with her eye? Huh?
What's up with - oh!
Is that - is that my wife? God why do I have such a shit eating grin here?
All right, okay put it down. I don't need to record that; I'm already handsome enough as it is.
Is that a tuba?
Where's the tro - there's the trump-pets! That's what I know how to play. Hello?
Ka-jank! Okay.
Ah! The old familiar class hallways,  wails of the damned and all.. okay.
Somthin' gonna pop out of me, yer-ah?
Principal!
My education!
It's so- oh - shit! I'm not supposed to actually look at you. Am I?
Who are you?
WHO ARE YOU?!
Ah that's even worse. All right? You know what, I got a few questions for you. Sir!
Wow you just-
Oh! He-ey! Oh!
Heeeeeey!
All right, then I didn't think you were a threat at all.
Oh hey. How's it going door?
Okay, what's this about? Responsibility?
I have none of that. Can you teach me how to do that?
Respect? I don't have none of that for nobody ex - especially me
and myself.
Kindness? Pleh. Bullshit-yness.
Tolerance, okay, all right. This is getting a little old.
Self-esteem? Nope. :(
Self-discipline? Neugh. Confidence? Oh-ho, no.
All right. Hello. Oh!
For some reason I did not expect that actually open.
Oh and it's a snowy day - night! This is what -
This is what people call night, usually.
I mistook it for day!
Oh hello
So what am I doing out here? I can't do -oooh- okay. All right then.
Hello, where am I supposed to go?
I guess follow this trail?
Oh.
Right then.. why am I actually here?
Whoa okay? Thank you! Wind! I guess?
Whoa-oh-oh-oh-okay!
Alright, I'm gonna fall!
Ow!
Ow! My lumbar!
Ah!
Ee!
I bruised my coccyx!
That's your butt bone!
You'd think my glasses is - hey! Hi!
You know-
I'm a lot of things.
Okay.
Okay. I'm gonna go with what idea that, I don't trust anybody.
Heh!
Yeah that's what I mean.
Yeesh!
Well, that's a weird thing to-
-have in existence and at all in reality and why, I mean weird isn't even the right word for that.
Oh yeah, real eloquent.
E-ugh.
Wh - da - wh- Don't lie!
Don't lie!
Yeah, okay? Yeah, you maybe should be little -
Alright. You should be a little suspicious to me because I don't think that's actually true
Heh, ha, heh, ha. I'm a liar.
Whoa-ow!
Ok yeah that seems good!
I don't trust you and I just lied to you. What would it matter if I told him that his daughter was dead?
That ain't no good at all
All right, you know-
Oh, thanks for that.
Oh Ethan's gonna treat me, right?
Don't tell me your last name's Bradbury.
Oh boy.
Okay, Ethan, I'm sure you're not gonna get some inconspicuous visitors at any moment here.
Yeah, I'm sure that's gonna be just fine
I'm gonna rest up.
Don't worry about Lynn or nothing.
Oh sleep. Yeah.
My wife-
-is pregnant and lost!
I'm gonna take a nap!
Here I go, then. I'm taking a fucking nap
I guess.
I mean, I might be going crazy maybe all this isn't real to begin with I mean, I don't even know where I am.
I went on to this quote unquote
"Reservation"
And reservation for what at this point?
Because it obviously isn't for its original purpose. So.
Who are these people and how did a cult form out in these woods?
And who's Jessica?!
Who's Jessica?!
Jessica sounds like someone that might have killed herself when they were kids.
Or maybe not? Maybe not killed herself?
Maybe was killed?
I know that voice!
It's pick-axe lady!
Eugh.
Oh-kay?!
Good thing that blocked you!
Run! Run Ethan! You treated me ri-i-i-ight!
Oh boy.
Ethan.
Maybe I should just go up there?!
Oh boy.
Oh-eugh.
Poor Ethan.
I'm - okay. Alright. I feel like maybe and I should stop being a little bit of a coward here.
And help!
Oh...
Oh.
You are not a friendly person!
YOU ARE NOT A HAPPY-GIVER!
You're not a smile-deliverer!
Oh no...
Yeah, you didn't think the - you'da think - thunked -
That maybe I could have been a bit of a-more of assistance for that.
Is he gonna still be alive?
Maybe.
Oh boy good for me - O-oh.
Eugh...
What a good guy!
Yeah, and I - I - da - didn't do you any good?
I guess he died with the happy idea that his daughter might be alive.
Like! I didn't wanna go down here!!
Down there's only bad memories.
Okay, I guess I'll take everything that I can here.
Oh, my head is wounded as it may be.
It's still in working condition.
Oof.
I'm sorry Ethan. :(
I liked you when you were alive, but -
Alas!
Things did not go the way they should have gone.
So I will carry on with your legacy inside my heart
and hope for better days 'round the corner.
Oh! Was that a flashlight?
I could probably use that.
Well, maybe not.
I don't even know what era we're in; I mean it must be some sort of modern era for me to a digital camera like this
But these people seem to be in slightly...
backwards times.
"Swimming is exhausting, find safe ground to recover" okay? Oh
Hello, hi
How are you doing? What are you doing?
What?
What what are you doing in the water?
Okay
Okay, you know what, I'm gonna find safe ground while you do that whatever you're doing over there
Come on - git - get up!
Servants of the enemy!
Don't hold 'em that close.
Oh.
Well that - I - I - I - Again, I don't know what that means,
but is - does that mean the heretics are gonna be doing things?
Euuugh!
Hello!
How are you?
You okay? How are ya doin? Ahh, you look good!
I mean, you've looked better probably,
but maybe not. I've.. this is the only time I've seen ya.
Let's go visit this lady and see what the hell she's up to.
Hey, lady, you want to give me some help?
You want to read me some bible verse-ooh.
Hide? Hide!? Get out of the barrel, you douche!
Peek?
Lemme just -
Hoh!
Oh, God. Oh God no!
It's a scarecrow.
Alright.
Well she seems to be gone. Can't carry any more bandages, which is good cause I don't think I need them
All right, what do we got? Chapter five and a -
You hold your fucking thought there!
I'm about to read!  ...and I looked in a gyre unwound from the night, a fire turned inward burning from all directions
Towards the center and drew the light from the walls of my room so that I hung in a void that shone in rainbows like oil
upon a black mirror - God they love run-on sentences -
...And I look despite the pain and behold, out of the midst of the inward fire came the likeness of a creature a
figure as like to a man as a circle is to a sphere as a
Cross-section of the sphere would make a circle so the cross-section of this creature would make a man
and this was their appearance; they had the appearance of Jesus Christ's agony upon the cross and in chest and sex had the appearance of
a man. And their faces were innumerable and joined to one another a thousand eyes and everywhere -
Weugh oh huehugh -
Sorry, spoke in tongues for a second there - a thousand eyes and everything a mouth with wings and jaws
Inseparable even inciting the purpose of the eyes and the purpose of the jaws was both for a more... perfect
Consumption. Thus were their faces and in the next moment
They were the bones of the Four Horses of the Apocalypse and the poems of the horsemen, too
and in the moment that they followed the faces and sex organs of angels and in the moment that have followed a
Bonfire of flame with voices singing and beauty to rend the mind and in the moment that followed a reflection in slivered glass
For their faces were all of these things at once and their wings were joined to one another as they flapped to move to arrest time
and I could not take air into my body.
I'm trying to channel the - the Knoth guy, his kind of voice and delivery there
I'll get it over time, gotta get that Southern drawl in there. Oh
You fucking crows!
Oh, hi. How's it going?
But you fucking crows!
You think you know things? You know nothing!
Oh boy.
Oh!
Hi, hello, hi hello hi. Hello
Hello!
How's it going?
What are you doing?
What are you doing over there?
Oh - I didn't wanna know about that.
What?
Uh oh!
Okay, oh, no, I lost it. Oh, no. I lost it! Oh
Oh hello. Hello. I'm gonna get you. I got the sickest zooms this side of the Mississippi!
Well, I was gonna have the sickest zooms this side of the Mississippi, but apparently not.
Okay, so what do I do about this? I can't exactly get out over there. Oh
That's the opposite of good.
Ohh!
No! Ooh! Here? Yes! Yes, nice slide into third base there!
Uh oh.
Eugh
Okay.
Euaugh -
Uhh...
(Mark's mating call)
Okay, gotta hide.
I think they were on to me for a second there, but if I hide...
Maybe I'll be able to get away from them because I remember I didn't do this too well in the demo!
And I'm not going to make the same mistakes that I did this time around
I'm going to survive and not get my junkle region removed via pickaxe.
That would be less than ideal.
You sons of bitches, you better find me a way out of here.
Is this way out of here? Better be the way out of here. I think this is. If I remember correctly -
Yes!
Yes!!
Yes!!!
YES!!!
Yes!!! Okay, okay, I don't think anyone's noticed me just yet.
Heuah!  Ohh!!
OohhaaaAAGH!
EUUGH!
Can't think I'm okay. I'm not okay. I'm not okay!
Eugh eugh eugh!
Oh hi! Okay, all right then, hello!
How are you doing? I'm not a - not a heretic or nothing!
Apparently, I just... birthed the anti-christ -
Ohhohoh ho ho ho!
Uh huh.
Uh huh?
Okay, all right then, calm down there sonny Jim.
All right. What do we got here?
"Interact." All right let's open this up, I'm sure this is gonna be quiet. How do they not notice me?
I've been sprinting through their camps, screaming at the top of my lungs. They should have drawn somebody's -
Oh, it saved.  Oh no.
Oh, hi. Uhh! I DIDN'T MEAN TO DO THAT!!
Oooh oh oh!
Oh God, oh God! Oh God, oh God.
Eugheugh eugh -
NnNNOOOOOOO!!
OWIE!!
Ow-hu-hu-wie! Owie!!
Why'd you do that to me?
You dick!
You dick!!  Oh, my God.
Why'd you do that to me? Son of a bitch! I didn't even do enough. Oh -
You sacks of shit.
Okay, where do I go from here? It seems like it might have been a dead end. Oh wait it is over here
Hello, all right? Well. I'll go up this way then
Squeeeezze...
Oh yeah, oh, I'm getting a lot of memories about this
Outlast sure does love its squeeze moments
Eugh, hi, how you doing there buddy? Ooo this looks fun. I'mma pull it! Oh -
Hi! Oh - I'm still pulling!! I don't know why.
Hello
You look like someone from... The Evil Within. Is there evil within... you!?
All right, I guess you're dead. You don't care (no shit)
Right then I'm gonna go this way then
[Lalalala]
Oh, God damn it, eugh!
Who did that!?
Who pulled that?!
Oh God.
Well, here gets my infected wound!
Eugh, gross...
Why?
Is it because it might be a horse of the apocalypse? Is that what it might be?
Oh geez.
I'm trying to remember what all the colorful language in that last chapter was - it was trying to paint the depiction of the
Oh, this is just a statue -it's trying to paint the depiction of what this guy was seeing as -
- beings of a higher dimension.
That's he was going for with the sphere and circle reference.
Soul of Christ make me ready, Father Knoth, guide my salvation, Blood of Christ, let me drink your wine--ah not close.
By the severed eye, give me vision. Angel of God, lend me your sword. Kind Jesus, hear my prayer Heal me in your wounds
You keep me close to you
Defend me from the wicked world and ready me for the Devil's hour in the fellowship of Temple gate
Then I might defend your creation until you give me rest, Amen. Okay. Maybe that's a secret message.
*Mark trying to find the secret message*
Yeah, I knew it! Okay. Goodbye
Gonna go this - woah, what was that?
Hide? In a barrel of blood? Really? I don't want to do dat...
You know how I - I usually have good ideas? I'm - I'm -
I'm gonna put that in the bad idea category.
Oh, hello - ow, why? Who did that?
Who the frick did that? Was what that?! (it was a cactus,dummy)
Hello? Oh, I hit a cactus! Oh, okay, I see how this is. Okay. All right.
*War of the Worlds Alien comin' for that booty!*
Why? Oh no, oh no, oh no...
It killed all the birds!
What the fuuuuuck?
The poor birds!
Awwwh!
I mean all the other dead bodies I've seen thus far - Yeah, okay, but the birdies!?
Awwwhhhh...
Alright then. Well that's sad, okay. Do I go down there or do I go through here?
Both those don't seem like good options, but I'm gonna go here first
Okay hello.
Can I pick that up, please? Thank you, there we go.
Alright this looks rickety
Well, I guess I can't go this way anyway
She's got to be - maybe through the mines? The horrible, horrible mines filled with death?
Huh? How about that? Oh, God. I thought it actually was going to be mines for a second there.
Awwh ohh....
The birdies...
Oh, is that a battery down there? Okay, I'll take that... Jeez ums.
What happened to this guy?
Why did Ethan have to die the moment that he tried to help me? That's how it always goes in these video games
Oh, this is a narrow ledge. No one bum me!
No one spook me with any other worldly influence, please I'm dragging you
All right fine the good morning
Oppa Do
"Peek from a ledge?"
In what world would that benefit me? Why would I need the peek from a goddamn ledge, okay?
I guess I'm going - oh, my God! Well that appeared out of nowhere
The world's worst Slip'n'Slide, here we go
down down into the depths
God damn - we ARE going into the mines aren't we?
My gamer sense tingled too hard, and I was right about this one... and I didn't wanna be-
Okay, oh boy. Oh, what is that?
What is that? What is that? What are you?
Freakin weirdo.
WHAM!
Oh, you're an expert on this all of a sudden. are you Blake? Well good for you!
Did Jessica give you an insight on that one, eehhh buddy?
That - well I think there's some cannibalism going on here, always good when there's cannibalism!
Hoopdee -
I made that jump... are you dicking me right now?
Ya fricking frack ol' -
Try this again..!
Okay, there you barely made it, you barely made it there. You tried to dick me over
And you barely made it.
Lemme use this bandage. "You don't need to use the bandage right now"?
I feel bad! Maybe I need it for my emotional wounds, did you ever think about that, game? I don't think they did
Right, away we -
How's it go - ah eeh what the fuck?
Alrighty then ooo lovely!
I like the decorations you've done with the place
It's adorable in fact!
Hey, if the piano man could stop clanging his instrument over there, I guarantee
That's not very good for it or me in general or anything for that matter
Lynn? Lynn?
Lynn?!
...Lynn?
Lynn?
Oh no...
Ohhhhh
Aaahhh!
AaaAAAhhah
Okay alright it's gone
AAHH I'm still freaked out about it
All right
I see what you're doing
...what the fuck?
Is that the moon?!
what?
Yeah, that's always good
Oh, fucking God damn it with this bullshit where am I?
Blake: The Chapel, somebody there will know where will know where they've taken Lynn
Mark: Why would someone there know that?
Why didn't you just go to the heretic place? You were at the heretic place! Unless that wasn't the main heretic place.
Weeee! Okay.
Oh, who the hell are you?!
Oh..No, oH nO, OH,NO.
Oh boy
Ahh! No, it's a trap! Oh god.
*sigh*
Fuck. I thought that was a trap
I legitimately thought that was a trap. I thought I was gonna die. I got flashbacks from Resident Evil
While I was playing Ethan must die. oh my God *laughs away*
Oh boy, okay.
So something happened there, but I can't get through this way
It looks like there's nothing good for me here, Anyway. I'm kinda puzzled here
Oh, I could just crawl through okay nevermind. I can just crawl through. Great, good.
Oh boy still the decorations
March nineth. More children dead.
Knoth says there is no sin in such infanticide,
as all our soldiers in God's army, Martyrs fallen on the field and defience of the Archfiend
All those babies with slit throats and charred flesh will be waiting immaculate for us in paradise.
Papa Knoth also says that our sins find us in our dreams. Our sins find us in our dreams.But my dreams are nothing
But the murder of my children and I wake laughing and aroused, and often wet with the *Wtfs* involuntary lust of--Ewagh
ewagh. I woke this morning thinking
I was wetted with the blood of my child's slit throat. But it was wetness of my own making the others of *slowly dies*
Weird voice:--tunnel so that we may
Normal voice:--meet in secret.We gather and share our visions and wonder at their meeting.
I feel increasingly this is a message, but nothing holy.
OKay, all right then so this is a 'heritic abode'!
Ah, lovely of course. Much like everything else the heretics have made here.
Alrighty then. Good for you, and your colorful language
Let's see what's going on here
Alright. Hellooo?
HELLOOOO?! I SHOut into the d--oh..
You alive? Oh fuck didn't mean to do that. You alive? (nope)
Are ya? I don't particularly trust ya.
But, okay. I'll take your word for it.
ugh. Is that Papa Knoth? Oh!
What a handsome fella that guy is
He's a great leader in this- - oh
*whispers* Fuck, why intestines..?
Why that- whatever that is.
Then what's up?
*Spooked Mark overload*
Male voice: And when his only
son said,
"Why hast thou forsaken me?"
he said not a word.
I am that I am.
I am!
that I am.
Mark: Okay, that doesn't mean anything
Male Voice: We stand guard by the gate through which the antichrist will breach this world.
We are at the cunt of armagedon
Mark: Ugh! Why?
Why?
Why would you s- Why would you say 'That'?!
Why is 'that' your word?!
All right then.
Sullivan Papa Ezekiel Liar Charlatan Temple of gout.
Addict. Coward. Rapist. Child-killer. I am gone,
And I have taken with me all with the courage to see the truth. Come after us. Hunt us down.
We are waiting and eager to murder and *laughs* fuck everybody you send up the mountain.
I don't hate you
Could Jesus hate the Baptist for being a Jew? I could not have found my true vision without your years of ignorance and bullshit.
I can never have had the courage to seek the truth if not fueled by my anger at your lies.
Your God is a child's superstition. Your faith is an embarrassment.The signs of the True Father were before you. Before us all. And you - -
vainglorious, gullible, too stupid to draw breath. You thought the visions were punishment from an angry and ominous God
Your God is afraid because your God is no god at all. Your God is your own ego,
Vulnerable and false. An embarrassment. My God is no god at all. But he is true.
And he is here in every moment of ecstasy. And his child will fuck and tear this world to everlasting glory.
I do not ask that you join us.
I tell you you will join us. Because our love is greater than you can ever imagine.
If there's one thing to describe out this letter, it's LOVE. And a lot of it. So anyway
I guess I'll end on the LOVELY note
So thank you everybody so much for watching. I'm going to carry on with this uh very soon. I'm gonna be doing a lot,
Of Outlast 2 and it is so much fun, and I love it.
So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always, I will see you, in the next video. Buh-bye!